hi everyone
welcome to another video tutorial on the
python series of videos by simply learn
today we are going to learn about
conditional statements in python
before i begin make sure to subscribe to
the simplyland channel to learn
interesting technologies
so let's get started conditional
statements in python perform
specific operations and take actions
depending on whether a specific boolean
constraint evaluates to true or false
conditional statements are handled by
blocks of if statements in python
now conditional statements are also
known as decision making statements
so python provides different types of
conditional statements that
you can use to make decisions we have
the simple
if statement then we have if else
statement
elif statement the nested if statement
as well as
nested if statement we will learn them
one by one with the help of the syntax
and code examples
so this is how the syntax of if
statement looks like so you pass in the
if condition
and then we have a set of statements
inside the if condition
so on the right side you can see the
flow diagram how the if statement gets
evaluated
so first we have the test expression
that is
the if condition now if this expression
evaluates to
true then we go inside the body of the
if statement so this is basically
the body of the if statement that
contains a list of statements or blocks
of statements
now if the test expression evaluates to
false
we execute the statements that are
present after the if condition
all right now let me take you to my
jupiter notebook
where we'll understand if statement with
an example
okay so here i am on my jupyter notebook
i'll just rename this to conditional
statements
i'll see it as demo and we'll rename it
okay i'll just expand the
screen size all right okay
so first of all let's
write a simple if statement i have given
a
comment here suppose we have a variable
called
grade
and the value of grade is 80 then i'll
write my
if statement as if grade
is greater than equal to
50 then i'll give a
colon then i'll write a print statement
print
passed in the exam
now this is how you write a simple if
statement so you have the if keyword
followed by the condition so here my
condition is
i'm checking whether the grade is
greater than equal to 50.
now here i've already defined my grade
to 80
so this if statement or the if condition
will check whether 80 is greater than
equal to 50. now this is true
then my print statement gets executed
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
here you can see we have our
printed message as passed in the exam
because 80 is greater than equal to
50. but what if i change this to let's
say
30. if i run this there is no output
here the reason being
30 is greater than equal to 50 is false
so my print statement did not execute
okay now if you want
you can also print
another statement outside the if
condition
i'll give the message as execute
statement after if
now one thing to remember that this
print statement is outside the if
condition
so if i run it only my
last print statement gets executed which
is outside the
ips condition okay
now let's write another simple
if statement now this time
we are not going to define the grade
value or
pre-define the grade value here we are
going to take the grade value as an
input that is a user input so i'll write
grade equal to now the way to take a
user input is by using the input
function
so first of all we need to convert
our entry into an integer so i'll write
int function and inside that i'll pass
in my input function
then
i'll give my message as enter the number
all right so this statement will take
the
number from the user now i'll write my
if statement if
grade is greater than equal to
50 then
it won't give a space here let's delete
this piece
then i'll write print
you have passed in the exam
okay
let's run it you see here
my program is asking for the user input
it says enter the number i'll give my
number as let's say
60. if i hit enter
that gives me the result passed in the
exam
now let's run it again this time i am
going to give as
let's say 35 if i run it
there is
no output here the reason being our
grade
35 is not greater than equal to 50 so
our print statement did not execute
all right okay now let me give a space
here we'll run it again
and this time we'll pass our grid as
let's say
75 let me run it
you can see here it gives me the message
passed in the exam now moving to our
next statement we have the if else
statement so this is how the
syntax of if else statement looks like
so first you have the
if condition followed by a colon
if this condition evaluates to true then
we execute the list of statements that
are present inside this if condition
else we have the else block here
if this condition returns false
then we execute the list of else
statements
so here is the flow of how the
if statement executes the different
statements
so first we check the test expression
if that evaluates to true then we have
the
body of if and if it is false
then we have the body of else
and later there are any statements that
are present outside the effects block
will execute those statements now let's
head over to our jupiter notebook and
we'll see
how the effect statement works by
example
okay so here i'll show you another
example
of using two if statements
so i'll define my grade as 40
i'll write if grade
is greater than equal to 50
then we'll print
let's see pass
then i'll write another if statement
i'll say grade is less than
50 then we'll print
fail
now here i'm using two if statements
let me run it you see here i have my
result as fail the reason being our
grade 40 is less than 50 and hence it
has printed fail
now instead of using two if statements
you can use the
if else statement so in this case
we'll have our if statement checked for
if grade is greater than equal to 50
if this is true then we'll print
whatever is there inside the if
statement
but in case this evaluates to false we
have another
else block that we are going to write
let me show you how to write the full
statement
so i'll give a comment as if else
okay i'll say
grade equal to 40
then we'll check if grade
is greater than equal to 50.
print pass
then instead of using
the if statement again i'll write else
followed by a colon and then i'll write
print fill make sure this field
is inside double quotations
if i run it it gives me the result fail
the reason being 40 is not less than
repeat 40 is not greater than equal to
50 so hence it has printed field
now instead of taking the value as 40
we can have the user give the input
so we'll use the input function i'll say
enter the
grade
let's run it again you see here my
program is asking for the user input
let's say i'll give 80 will
run it it says pass because 80 is
greater than equal to 50
let me run it again this time let's say
i'll pass
my grade as 45 will run it
it gives us fail all right
now moving to our next
conditional statement we have the
ellipse statement
now this is how the syntax of ellipse
statement looks like
so here first we have the if condition
now if the if condition evaluates to
true
we have the body of if there is
basically a set of statements
now if the first test expression or the
if condition evaluates to false
then our alif condition gets executed
now if our l if condition is true
then we have the body of alif so this is
the ellipse statement body
finally if the alif condition also
evaluates to false
then we have the block of else
statements you can see here
we have body of else and later if there
are any statements outside this
if alif and else block then those
statements get executed
now we'll see this with the help of
examples
okay so here on my
cell i'll give my comment as
left statement
okay suppose i have a variable called
score
and this take the value
as integer from the user so i'm using
the input function
i'll say enter
the score
i'll give a space then
i'll write my if condition i'll say if
score is
let's say greater than equal to 90
give a colon then we'll print
our message has passed the
exam with let's say agreed
i'll just copy this statement because we
are going to
print similar statement
below as well and now i'll have my
alif condition i'll write lf
alif is actually else if score
is greater than equal to
let's say 75
i'll give a colon we'll print
past the exam with
b grade then i'll again have my
alif statement i'll write if score
is greater than equal to let's say
60
will print pass the exam with
c grade
next let's write another alif condition
i'll write lf
if score is greater than
this should be greater than equal to
okay
is greater than equal to let's say
40 then we'll print
past the exam with degrade
and finally we'll have the
else condition i'll write print
let me just scroll down
field in the exam
ok so this is how you write a
life conditional statement so first i am
taking the user input of the score
then i am checking if score is greater
than equal to 90
i am displaying my message as pass the
exam with a grade
then i have a list of alif statements
to check for different scores if
all these evaluates to false i am having
my
else statement printed let's
run it okay so we'll try out different
scores let's say
someone's code 95
if i run it so that candidate
has passed the exam with e-grade because
if you see the condition my score 95 is
greater than equal to 90 and hence we
have
passed the exam with a grade as the
message run it again
let's say i have 80. if i run it
it says pass the exam with b grade the
reason being
80 is greater than equal to 75 and hence
we have this message printed
let's run it again suppose someone
scored let's say 25.
far on it okay it throws me an error
it says name score
not defined okay so this should be score
actually
here there was a spelling mistake i'll
run it
i'll pass my score as 25 it gives me
failed in the exam the reason being my
score
25 is less than equal to 40 and hence we
have
failed in the exam cool
now you can also use a for loop and then
have a list of
refers block or if else statements
let me show you how to do it suppose i
write
for x in i'll use the range function
i'll go till 10 which means from 0 to 9
then i'm checking if my x
is less than equal to 3
i'll print x
is less than or
equal to 3
okay now we have the
ellipse statement if alif
x greater than 5
i'll print x
is
greater than
five
then we have the else condition
will print let me just scroll down
i'll print x
must be
four or five
okay so
here i have used a for loop and i am
[Music]
checking for each iteration from zero to
9 and then we have a set of
if elephant else statements let's run it
there you go you can see the output here
so first
in my range i have 0 so it will check
if 0 is less than equal to 3 which is
true so it has printed 0 is less than or
equal to 3.
so it will go till 3 and then
when 4 comes it will check if 4
is greater than 5 now this is also false
so it will skip
executing the lf statement and it will
print whatever is there in the
else block which is
4 must be 4 or 5. so you can see the
message here 4 must be 4 and 5.
similarly for 5 also the same message
will be printed the reason being
5 is not greater than 5 and then for the
rest of the
numbers from 6 to 9 we have
6 is greater than 5 7 is greater than 5
8 is greater than 5 and 9 is greater
than 5
all right
now moving ahead
next we have the nested if statement
so here is the syntax of nested if so
you have the if condition
and inside the if condition you have
another if condition and hence it
becomes the
nested if condition statement and inside
this
condition you have the list of
statements or the blocks of statements
so here is how the flowchart or the flow
diagram looks like
so first we are evaluating the
expression1 which is this condition
if it is true we are going inside and
checking the second condition
if that is also true then we are running
the body of it which is this
part of the syntax and later if there
are any
statements that are present outside the
if condition we are executing those
so in case the first test expression
evaluates to false
we are coming outside and directly
printing
whatever is there outside
the if condition let's
see this with the help of an example
okay so i'll give my comment here as
nested if cool
so first of all i'll declare a variable
called num
now this num will have a
user input value so i'll write input
enter the number
then i'll have my first
if condition i'll say if
number or num is less than 250
i'll give a colon
then we'll use the print statement
num is
smaller than 250.
i'll write my second if statement
and we'll check if num is less than
180 and will print
num is
smaller than
180 as well
finally i'll have my else statement as
print number
is
greater than
180
all right let's run this and first we'll
check
with the number 100 okay there you go
so here i'm checking whether 100 is less
than 250 which is true
so we have printed 100 is smaller than
250 again we are checking if
100 is less than 180 which is true again
so we are printing 100 is smaller than
180 as well there is a spelling mistake
okay now let's see for let's see 150
again we have 150 smaller than 250 150
also smaller than 180
let's run it this time let's say we'll
pass 300
okay you can see our result here
300 is less than 250 is false
so we'll skip printing this again we'll
check whether 300 is less than 180
which is false again so we'll skip
printing this statement as well
we'll only have our else block printed
which is 300 is
greater than 180 okay
now coming to the final section where we
will see about
nested files so here you can see we have
the syntax for nested
if else statement so we have an outer if
condition
and inside that we have another if
condition
then we have the list of
statements or the body of the if
condition if this is false then we
execute the
else part and after that we also have an
outer else statement so this is how
the flow diagram looks like we'll check
for the test expression one
if that is true then we'll go inside and
see the test expression
two and if that is true we'll execute
the body of
if statement which is this part of the
syntax
then if these are false then we'll see
the
body of else one if the second
expression is false then we go to the
body of else two
and after that if there are any more
statements we'll execute them as well
all right we'll see an example here
so i'll give my comment as
nested if else
okay so i'll declare a variable a
which will take a user input
of type integer i'll say
enter the
number i'll write if
a is less than 50
so this is my first if condition
if this is true it should be less than
50
okay so if my first if statement is true
then we'll
check for the second if statement which
is let's say if
a modulus 3
equal to equal to 0 which means if the
remainder of the division is 0
then we say print
a
divisible
by 3 and
is less than 50
okay
then we have our else statement
as else
print my number e
is not
divisible by 3
but is
less than 50
finally i'll have my
last else statement
where i'll print my number a
is greater
than 50. okay so this is how you write a
nested if full statement so i am taking
my
number as a user input first i am
checking that number is less than 50.
if that is true i am again checking if
that number is divisible by 3
if it is divisible i am printing my
message as the number
e is divisible by 3 and is less than 50.
if this is false i am saying the number
e is not divisible by 3 but it is less
than
50 else i am saying the number is
greater than 50.
let's run this and we'll try out
different
examples let's say i'll say my number is
12.
my message is 12 is divisible by 3 and
is less than 50
which is this part of the code so my
number 12 is less than 50.
this is true then i'm again checking
whether 12 is divisible by 3
it evaluates to true and hence we have
this result printed
okay let's say this time i'll say 30
so i have my message 30 is divisible by
3 that is less than 50.
let's run it again and this time let's
say we'll say 72
so here i have my message 72 is greater
than 50. the reason being
72 less than 50 is false
hence this part of the code is not
executed it will directly come to the
else part
which says 72 is greater than 50. okay
so that brings us to the end of this
demonstration on conditional statements
in python
so first we learned how to write simple
if statement you saw how to
take inputs from the user
we also learnt how to write if
statement then you learnt about
elif statement you also saw how to use a
for loop
and inside that you can use your if
statement your lf your else
later on we saw how to write nested if
statements
and finally we learned how to write
nested if statements
cool so that brings us to the end of
this video tutorial on
conditional statements in python i hope
it was useful and informative if you
have any queries then please feel free
to put them in the comments section of
the video thank you for watching and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here